[Musique]
en tant qu on les a pas regardés aux
autres on les avait mis là on avait
beaucoup de l'argent n'est moins de
l'âge maintenant si je ferai juste un
petit peu un petit petit petit flat âge
de saint pie xi juste pour dire qu'on
enlève des petites taches cochonneries
g250 piles de bois d'un grand bâtiment
de 100 pieds de long par contre 25 en
pied de la roche qui est plein à craquer
marie claude vézina travailler dans le
milieu communautaire de sherbrooke mail
envie de changement occuper son esprit
c'est bien qu'elle a décidé de changer
sa vie du tout au tout et devient
propriétaire d'une entreprise de vente
de bois de grange pour moi trop facile c
est plate
donc c'était pas facile du tout à la
chaudronnée mais j'étais rendu à vouloir
faire d'abord un autre défi la drève de
dans le stress l'énergie d'un nouveau
défi et michel baldwin a été atteint
d'un cancer et ou en septembre 2012 en
passant par hasard pour venir lui dire
celle du il me disait qu'il y avait des
gens de l'ontario qui auraient été
intéressés à prendre leur acheter son
entreprise mais quasiment tout liquider
la période de réflexion a été de courte
durée pour cette amoureuse du bois elle
devait acheter et vivre de sa passion
une passion qui remonte à son enfance
le grain est beau mon père a toujours
adoré le bo est détesté la peinture
quand il y avait on avait un chalet
quand j'étais jeune dans le coin du de
rhinos finale bas du fleuve et qui a
décidé de transformer sa commère
résidence principale il ya mis des
planches de pin sur tous les murs et
c'est tout surtout les plafonds j'avais
12-13 ans à l'époque
aujourd'hui elle est à nouveau entouré
de bois moi c'est une oeuvre d'art
c'étaient des armes faut s'imaginer que
c'était un arbre qui ça a été fait à la
hache
ça ça m'étonne encore ça m'épate encore
il ya des fois que j'essaie retrait
morceau que les gens veulent l'acheter
puis je leur vends mes joueuses matrix
qui partent avec certains morceaux
je me fais des cachettes pour moi des
fois mais là des cachettes qui serviront
sans doute plus tard pour l'instant elle
se consacre entièrement ses clients elle
veut donner un service personnalisé mais
aussi faire une différence à sa manière
tout le bois objets que les gens viens
de m'acheter
c'est autant d'arbres qui sont coupés
c'est autant de machines polluantes qui
coupent les arbres kiki encore peut-être
un peu moins j'aime penser à sow donc
j'ai fait ce que je voulais ça vaut bien
[Musique]
si maria l'iman radio canada ben oui